i'm adam sanchez and i'll be making some
chorizo sliders it's going to be
delicious i'm actually a third
generation cookbook author i guess it
was in the jeans and that's how i
started to amass my own style where you
kind of cook a dish and you close your
eyes and they know that that's an aron
sanchez dish what i love about sliders
is that you can basically have any
combination of flavors you want you know
chorizo in itself has so much seasoning
that it really just does a great job
carrying all that through to the bread
and then to the jalapeno aioli it just
makes for that really perfect bite you
can really have fun and interpret this
recipe the way you want i would ideally
do this for a summer cookout with my
kids and just having a good time a lot
of us agree that our grandmothers are
probably the best cooks in their
families summers for me meant going back
to el paso saturday mornings going to my
grandmother's house and she was really
cute she was like i don't want you guys
to stop on on me without calling me i
have to put on nice makeup
what makes this chorizo slider recipe
very heartfelt is that in my family's
ranch in northern mexico where my mom
and my grandmother grew up i remember
this big mint bush to the outside the
kitchen and my grandmother would make
meatballs and garnish it with the mint
there's a real simple technique to
produce these in mass buy yourself a
dozen of the dinner rolls and actually
slice them right in half whole and it
allows you to really control all the
different components in your slider
something that's floral and perfumey
like mint i think works with the
savoriness and the spice of the chorizo
sliders it's loaded with flavor and it's
something that everyone at home can
really make those kind of dishes really
speak to me you know it's different
being a chef now and kind of all the
things i do sometimes i don't get to get
in the kitchen as much as i like so i
tend to cook a lot at home now i'm
reminded constantly of the therapy
that's involved when you cook just makes
me at ease
oh
[Music]
yes you